Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Alors aujourd'hui, je suis toujours dans le même cadre, en fait, j'attends
d'aménager mon bureau pour pouvoir filmer toutes mes vidéos dans mon bureau.
Pour l'instant, je continue de filmer devant ma bibliothèque, mais d'ici le
début de l'année prochaine, normalement, je devrais pouvoir filmer dans mon
bureau.
Également, j'ai fixé le microphone directement à ma veste, à ma polaire, pour
éviter de le tenir, parce que parfois, je me suis rendu compte que parfois, ça
faisait des petits frottements et des bruits qui n'étaient pas vraiment
agréables.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui est que quand on apprend une
langue, on se dit, ou même sans apprendre une langue, on se dit souvent, non
mais si je veux parler cette langue, il faut que j'habite dans le pays.
Si je veux parler français il faut que j'aille habiter en France sinon je ne pourrai jamais apprendre
Et idem dans mon cas si je veux apprendre le japonais il faut que j'habite au Japon sinon je n'arriverai jamais à parler japonais
Et du coup, cette idée qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser une langue si on n'habite pas
dans le pays.
C'est faux. Enfin, c'est faux. Je vais m'expliquer.
J'avais envie de parler de ce sujet pour plusieurs raisons.
En fait, j'ai envie d'expliquer pourquoi je ne pense pas qu'habiter dans un
pays, ça va forcément vous aider à apprendre la langue.
Pourquoi habiter dans un pays ne nous rend pas automatiquement bilingue ou à un
niveau avancé dans la langue.
Souvent, on a cette image, on se dit, si j'habite dans le pays, je vais
entendre régulièrement la langue, je vais pratiquer et du coup, je vais devenir
bon dans la langue.
Je vais pouvoir parler facilement sans trop de difficultés.
Et ça, c'est une erreur.
Pour commencer, j'ai l'exemple du Japon.
En 2020, avec ma femme, on est allé pour la première fois au Japon pendant des
vacances, pendant deux semaines.
C'était juste avant le Covid.
On est parti deux semaines en fin janvier, début février.
Et en mars, c'était le confinement.
Et en fait, au retour de ce voyage, on a commencé à apprendre le japonais.
On a commencé à apprendre le japonais parce qu'on avait pour objectif d'aller
passer plus de temps au Japon.
Et notamment de faire une année sabbatique au Japon.
L'année dernière, en 2024, on a passé un an au Japon.
Et en fait, on a pu, enfin, j'ai pu faire l'expérience de voir si habiter dans
un pays, ça m'aidait vraiment à apprendre la langue.
Le premier exemple, c'est que quand on est arrivé, on a commencé à apprendre des
cours de japonais dans la ville où on habitait.
Dans Tokyo, il y a plein de villes, c'est plein de petites villes.
Et on habitait dans une petite ville où il y avait des vieilles personnes qui
nous donnaient des cours de japonais.
Pendant ces cours, en fait, on a rencontré un couple de Canadiens qui habitaient
depuis 4 ans ou 5 ans au Japon.
Et en fait, ça faisait 4 ans qu'ils habitaient au Japon.
Mais ils débutaient tout juste leur apprentissage de japonais.
Alors, je ne dis pas ça pour critiquer, mais c'est juste que c'est pour vous
montrer qu'habiter dans un pays ne suffit pas à apprendre une langue.
Pourquoi ça ne suffisait pas pour eux pour apprendre une langue ?
Pourquoi habiter 4 ans au Japon n'a pas été suffisant pour apprendre une langue
?
Tout simplement parce que, comme ils parlaient anglais, quand ils sont arrivés,
ils parlaient anglais.
Ils ne parlaient pas du tout japonais.
Et du coup, très rapidement, leur vie s'est organisée en anglais.
Leur travail était un travail en anglais.
Tous leurs collègues, souvent, parlaient anglais.
Et du coup, préféraient parler en anglais parce qu'ils ne parlaient pas du tout
japonais.
Et du coup, pareil, après, pour les supermarchés, etc., en général, même si
c'est des toutes petites phrases, on peut s'en sortir avec de l'anglais.
Même si au Japon, ils ne parlent pas très bien anglais.
Et du coup, il y a cette dimension où, en fait, on a beau habiter dans le pays,
on peut très vite se retrouver à vivre en anglais, en fait, à juste parler
anglais.
Et ça, ça peut être même le cas dans une ville comme Paris.
Idem, avec ma femme, du coup, on avait appris à parler, on avait appris le
japonais.
On commençait à avoir un niveau débutant intermédiaire en japonais.
Et on a habité dans une colocation, donc dans une maison avec plusieurs autres
personnes, dont des japonais.
On avait des colocataires japonais.
Et en fait, la plupart du temps, on parlait en anglais.
On a déjà essayé, quelquefois, de parler en japonais avec eux, mais c'est juste
que notre niveau de japonais n'était pas suffisant pour avoir une discussion
sans que ce soit un peu embêtant, sans que ce soit difficile de vraiment dire
quelque chose.
Et en fait il suffit de se mettre à la place de la personne
Si je suis en France et qu'il y a une personne étrangère qui arrive et qui
essaye de me parler en français, mais qui a du mal, au bout d'un moment, je peux
l'aider de temps en temps.
Mais quand c'est dans la vie de tous les jours, quand c'est des discussions dans
la vie de tous les jours, au bout d'un moment, c'est juste plus efficace de
parler anglais.
D'autant plus que, bon, moi, je donne des cours de français, donc j'ai
l'habitude d'essayer de parler lentement, clairement, pour essayer de faire
comprendre le mieux possible aux personnes avec lesquelles je parle.
Mais quand ce n'est pas du tout quelque chose dont vous avez l'habitude, quand
vous n'avez pas du tout l'habitude de parler comme ça, d'enseigner votre langue,
en fait, c'est juste difficile et vous ne le faites pas.
Donc, si on n'a pas vraiment un très bon niveau dans la langue, si on n'a pas un
bon niveau plutôt, tout de suite, ça crée une barrière à l'arrivée dans le pays.
Du coup, l'idée, c'est que juste habiter dans le pays ne va pas vous aider à
apprendre une langue pour plusieurs raisons.
La première, c'est que plus la langue est difficile, plus l'idée d'attendre,
d'habiter dans le pays pour apprendre la langue est une mauvaise idée.
Si je prends mon cas, je suis français, donc je parle une langue latine.
Si demain, je vais vivre en Espagne, bon, je n'ai pas trop besoin de me
préparer.
Je peux aller directement en Espagne, commencer à travailler mon espagnol sur
place.
Et dans ce cas-là, ça devrait pouvoir fonctionner.
Tout simplement parce que les barrières à l'entrée, les obstacles, tout ce que
j'ai à apprendre, c'est assez proche du français, donc ça va s'activer beaucoup
plus rapidement.
Alors que pour le japonais, c'est complètement différent.
Il y a plein de choses qu'il faut apprendre, qu'il faut pouvoir maîtriser.
Et en fait, si vous attendez d'être sur place, ça va vous faire perdre du temps
parce que vous allez passer énormément de temps à apprendre des choses.
Pour apprendre ces choses, vous n'aviez pas besoin d'être dans le pays.
Vous n'aviez pas besoin d'être en France pour apprendre certaines choses.
Et je n'avais pas besoin, par exemple, d'être au Japon pour apprendre les
alphabets, les caractères japonais.
Par exemple, les kanji, il y a 2000 kanji à apprendre.
Et en fait, que vous soyez au Japon ou en France, ça ne change rien.
Ce n'est pas parce que vous êtes sur place que vous allez apprendre plus vite.
L'apprentissage va être le même.
Et en général, ça va quasiment demander le même temps d'apprentissage.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment pour la partie théorique.
Ce sont des choses que vous devez apprendre et que, même si vous êtes dans le
pays, vous aurez toujours autant de mal à apprendre.
Par exemple, la conjugaison en français, c'est quelque chose que, si vous voulez
maîtriser, autant l'apprendre avant de venir en France.
Plus la langue est difficile, plus il y a des différences avec votre propre
langue, plus cet aspect théorique de la langue vaut le coup d'être étudié avant
d'aller dans le pays.
Si vous attendez d'être dans le pays pour tout apprendre ça ne sert à rien vous allez perdre du temps
Donc voilà, il y a cette idée de, en fait, moi, avant d'aller au Japon, j'ai
appris beaucoup de kanji, de caractère japonais, hérité par nom du chinois.
Et en fait, si je n'avais pas fait ça, ben, j'aurais dû le faire exactement de
la même façon au Japon.
Donc ça aurait été une perte de temps.
Donc, plutôt que d'attendre d'habiter dans le pays, vous pouvez gagner du temps
en apprenant les choses théoriques pour ensuite pouvoir les mettre en pratique
dans le pays.
La conjugaison, pouvoir l'utiliser en France, par exemple.
La deuxième raison, c'est que si vous n'avez pas un niveau minimum dans la
langue, ce n'est pas un avantage d'habiter dans le pays.
Je disais que je pouvais aller en Espagne pour commencer directement à
apprendre.
Tout simplement parce qu'en français, bon, c'est cliché et c'est faux, mais on
dit, bon, à la fin du mot, on rajoute un O et ça donne de l'espagnol.
Si vous mettez un O ou un A à la fin d'un mot, ça va devenir de l'espagnol.
On dit un problème et on va dire problema, si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Et du coup, on peut facilement faire le lien entre les deux langues.
Mais en fait, ça, du coup, ça nous assure d'avoir un niveau minimum parce que si
vous n'avez pas ce niveau minimum, ça ne sera en aucun cas un avantage.
Si vous ne connaissez rien du japonais, vous aurez beau être au Japon, vous ne
pourrez rien dire.
Et ça ne servira à rien d'habiter sur place parce que tout sera une barrière.
Si vous n'apprenez pas tous les alphabets japonais, vous ne pouvez pas lire.
Et du coup, ça ne sert à rien d'être dans les rues de Tokyo avec beaucoup de
japonais écrits.
C'est un cas particulier parce que là, on parle de l'écriture, on parle de la
lecture.
Mais il y a des choses assez similaires en français.
La conjugaison, par exemple.
La conjugaison, c'est très chiant.
Mais c'est quelque chose que...
Si vous apprenez la conjugaison assez rapidement, sans passer trop de temps avec
tous les s à la fin, etc.
Si vous vous souvenez juste des structures, des verbes à chaque temps,
ça peut être très utile pour accélérer votre apprentissage.
Si vous arrivez et que vous savez reconnaître tel ou tel temps,
ça va vous aider à vraiment aller beaucoup plus vite.
La conjugaison, le but, ce n'est pas de savoir écrire avec le s à la fin à la
bonne personne, etc.
Mais c'est plus savoir reconnaître quel est le temps du verbe.
Et tout ça, pour finir sur la troisième raison, c'est qu'il y a des choses
incompressibles.
Incompressibles, ça veut dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas être compressés.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, vous avez une somme de connaissances.
Vous avez tout ça à apprendre dans la langue.
Et quand vous allez habiter sur place, ça va rendre l'apprentissage plus
efficace.
Donc ça va prendre moins de temps.
Mais ça ne peut pas être compressé à l'infini.
Dans tous les cas, ça prendra du temps.
Et autant commencer avant d'habiter dans le pays.
Votre cerveau, il a besoin de digérer.
Quand on mange, on passe notre ventre, après digère la nourriture.
Notre cerveau, c'est pareil.
Quand on lui envoie des informations, il faut qu'il ait le temps de digérer
l'information pour qu'on puisse apprendre de nouveaux mots de vocabulaire, etc.
J'avais fait une vidéo sur les techniques de mémorisation.
Il y a des techniques efficaces, mais ce n'est pas compressible à l'infini.
Quand il faut apprendre 2000 caractères chinois, ce n'est pas compressible.
Ce n'est pas parce que vous habitez dans le pays que vous allez apprendre
beaucoup, beaucoup plus vite.
Et du coup, si vous n'apprenez pas avant d'aller habiter dans le pays, vous
allez perdre du temps.
Il faut imaginer, si je dois prendre une image, il faut imaginer que dans votre
tête, il y a quelqu'un qui prend les informations comme des livres et qui les
range dans les bibliothèques.
Sauf qu'en fait, cette personne, si vous lui envoyez un camion de livres, si
vous lui envoyez 1000 livres d'un coup, elle va être paniquée, elle va prendre
du temps pour ranger les livres.
Et tant que les livres ne sont pas rangés, c'est que l'information n'est pas
disponible dans votre tête et que vous n'avez pas appris un nouveau mot de
vocabulaire ou autre chose, une autre information.
Et du coup, ça, il faut savoir anticiper, il faut prendre le temps et après, ça
demande aussi de l'entraînement.
Plus on apprend, plus ça devient efficace.
Mais du coup, voilà, mon point de cette vidéo, c'est plus d'expliquer que c'est
un faux argument de dire, je vais attendre d'habiter sur place pour apprendre la
langue.
Et mon point, c'est plutôt que c'est très important d'arriver avec un niveau
intermédiaire, de savoir un peu parler.
Si vous arrivez avec un niveau intermédiaire, c'est là où votre apprentissage va
être maximisé, c'est là où vous allez progresser le plus rapidement possible.
Tout simplement parce que toutes les barrières à l'entrée, tout ce qui est
théorie ou qui est un peu... qui demande du temps à mémoriser,
tout ça, vous l'aurez déjà fait et vous pourrez pleinement apprendre la langue,
à parler de nouvelles expressions, de nouveaux mots.
sans trop devoir vous concentrer sur la partie technique de la langue.
Et du coup, mon point là-dessus, c'est que c'est vraiment important d'arriver
avec un niveau intermédiaire
pour pouvoir progresser, mais aussi parce que ce niveau intermédiaire, il va
vous ouvrir des portes.
Pendant l'année qu'on a eu au Japon, ça a été une année exceptionnelle, on a
vécu, pardon, des moments uniques.
Et je pense que 70% de ces moments, c'était seulement parce qu'on parlait un peu
japonais.
On n'avait pas du tout un niveau parfait, mais disons que si on allait dans une
soirée,
si on allait au restaurant avec un japonais qui ne parle pas anglais,
on pouvait quand même échanger et parler un peu de nos vies.
Et rien que ça, en fait, ça ouvre des portes et ça ouvre plein de possibilités.
Parce que si on avait rencontré ces personnes sans pouvoir parler japonais,
juste en parlant anglais, on n'aurait pas pu échanger.
Juste un exemple, à un moment, on a rencontré l'ami d'un de nos colocataires.
Donc nos colocataires parlaient anglais, mais son ami ne parlait que japonais.
On a sympathisé avec cet ami et on a rencontré ses parents qui nous ont tout de
suite invités chez eux
à venir passer 3-4 jours chez eux dans les montagnes au Japon.
Et on a fini par se retrouver à la campagne japonaise, dans une famille qui ne
parlait pas du tout anglais,
donc on parlait seulement en japonais.
On était très nul, enfin on n'était pas assez bon et du coup il y avait beaucoup
d'hésitation, d'erreurs, etc.
Mais on a vécu des moments uniques, on est allé skier au Japon.
Tout ça grâce à un niveau un peu débutant intermédiaire de japonais.
Donc tout cet apprentissage que vous faites avant d'aller dans le pays,
ça va vous ouvrir des portes, ça va vous faciliter votre vie sur place une fois
que vous arrivez.
Et vous allez pouvoir vivre des moments uniques avec des locaux.
Si vous arrivez en France et que vous allez dans la campagne française,
il vaut mieux parler un peu français.
Et si vous rencontrez des Français dans la campagne et que vous parlez un peu
français,
je suis sûr qu'ils vous accueilleront à bras ouverts et qu'ils seront très
accueillants
et qu'ils vous partageront des moments uniques.
On a toujours l'image de Paris avec les gens pas très agréables,
mais c'est pareil dans toutes les grandes villes.
Dans Tokyo, on n'a pas fait de... à part nos colocataires,
on n'a pas rencontré par hasard des personnes avec qui on a eu des expériences
particulières.
Tout simplement parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde,
tout le monde est pressé, il y a beaucoup d'étrangers.
Mais par contre, dès qu'on allait à la campagne au Japon,
les gens étaient surpris de nous voir,
on parlait un peu, donc on pouvait échanger un peu avec eux
et ça nous ouvrait plein de portes,
on a pu avoir des expériences inoubliables.
Et je pense que c'est exactement la même chose en France.
Donc, si vous attendez de vivre en France pour apprendre le français,
arrêtez, enfin du moins,
commencez tout de suite à apprendre un peu de français,
ça vous sera toujours utile une fois sur place.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'à la fin
et je vous dis à la prochaine.